more than a decade after he was first
accused of sexually abusing dozens of
girls a politically connected
multi-millionaire has told a judge that
he conspired to silence them Jeffrey
Epstein is accused of luring the
underage teens to his Florida mansion
and then sexually assaulting them all of
it beginning in 2001 and in a surprise
move yesterday Epstein settled an
ongoing civil lawsuit that would have
exposed details of the sexual abuse
allegations against him shreeka Duncan
is at the courthouse in West Palm Beach
Florida
trick' good morning good morning it is
here where Epstein's lawyer dropped that
civil suit and basically in the process
admitted that Epstein was trying to do
everything that he could to stop those
alleged victims from speaking Jeffrey
Epstein did not apologize directly to
his accusers Tuesday but through his
lawyers said his attempts to silence
them and their attorney were wrong
Epstein had also been trying to derail a
lawsuit filed by his accusers in 2008
which says investigators identified more
than 30 girls who were told they were
being hired to give Epstein massages but
were sexually assaulted instead Epstein
often preyed on teenagers from broken
homes
that's according to accusers who spoke
with the Miami Herald and he tried to
put his finger in my underwear and I
like jumped back and I went I pulled
back and I was like Hello
but Epstein was never charged in most of
those cases in 2007 he struck a secret
deal with federal prosecutors who let
him plead guilty to two lesser sex
charges in state court he served just 13
months in a County Jail the deal was
approved by then US attorney Alex Acosta
now the Secretary of Labor in the Trump
administration I don't think there's a
person in America who would ever look at
the facts of this case and believe that
there was even an actual punishment
attorney Brad Edwards says his clients
were kept in the dark over Epstein's
arrangement why do you think it happened
that's what we're still trying to
uncover one reason that we know are
factors money and power
Whitewater special prosecutor Ken Starr
and Harvard Law Professor Alan
Dershowitz were part of epstein
star-studded defense team back then at
the time of his arrest Epstein was a
powerful money manager who handled
billions for his clients his circle of
friends included Prince Andrew Donald
Trump and former President Bill Clinton
who reportedly took at least 26 trips on
Epstein's private jet between 2001 in
2003 in 2002 Donald Trump told New York
magazine
Epstein quote likes beautiful women as
much as I do
and many of them are on the younger side
how many more victims do you think are
out there local victims have said that
when there were 14 15 years old they
brought 25 30 girls to him that's just
one person nobody has really had the
opportunity or ability to see how deep
this goes in any other jurisdiction on
Tuesday some members of Congress asked
the Department of Justice Inspector
General to open an investigation now
federal prosecutors and since they did
everything proper but as you can imagine
those alleged victims disagree now
according to Edwards it's unlikely but
he says technically Epstein could still
face criminal charges Gail so disturbing
on so many levels thank you very much
jurika